[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر بركي
احييكم وانا راويه القاسم وهذه العربيه
160 الخبر من كل الزوايا من جميع الجوانب
[موسيقى]
تصف قرارات شيكو بالعار وفوتنا المضطر
يبحث للجيش المرتبك على حساب المتطوعين
الاكفا
استياء امريكي من انشطه الصين التجسسيه
فمن اكبر متجسس في العالم واشنطن وعلى من
الحلفاء قبل الخطوط
الاصطناعي وخطابه الاخير في ميزان الدستور
المغالطات ضغط على الحقائق
وتتابعون معنا الليله ايضا
[موسيقى]
السيارات الكهربائيه نظيفه وامنه لكن مكون
واحد في بطارياتها ينتج سموما تملا نحو
الفي حمام سباحه سنويا
[موسيقى]
في حلقه جديده من الصراع بين الجيش الروسي
ومجموعه فاجنر الخاصه وصف مؤسس المجموعه
طلب وزاره الدفاع الروسيه من المتطوعين
توقيع عقود بانه عار واقترح حلا وسطا يحصل
فيه المتطوعون على ضمانات اجتماعيه ووثائق
كمشاركنا في الاعمال القتاليه لكن لا يبدو
ان فاجنر ستحصل على ما تريد لان الرئيس
الروسي اظهر مؤشرات على انه سينحاز الى صف
الجيش في هذا الصراع
عندما شاركنا لاول مره في هذه الحرب لم
يقل احد اننا سنكون مضطرين لتوقيع صفقات
مع وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
لا احد من مقاتل باجنر مستعد للسير في
طريق العار هذا مره اخرى لهذا السبب لا
احد منهم سيوقع العقود
لحظات محرجه والتفاته فتحت الباب امام
التكهنات الكتف البارد الذي اعطاه الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين لوزير دفاعه
لم يفهم ما اذا كان اهانه ام غضبا لكن
البعض فسره على انه استياء ربما من اداء
شويغو اما موقف بوتين فيبقى واضحا بانه
لنحياز للميليشيات على حساب القوات
النظاميه
النزاع بين مجموعه فاغنر والجيش بلغ اشده
وبوتين في مسعا لاخضاع القوات غير
النظاميه المقاتله في اوكرانيا لسلطه
وزاره الدفاع دعما لمبادره التي رفض
الانصياع لها مؤسس فاجنر بروجين وفق صحيفه
البريطانيه الى انه مع خطوات بوتين التي
تتماهى مع ما يريده الجيش تزداد الصعوبات
التي يواجهها
خاصه بعد ان تعهد بعدم العمل تحت قياده
شويغو صراحه وشكى ايضا من رغبه الجيش في
ابعاد مجموعته عن ساحه المعركه في
اوكرانيا
فمؤسس فاجنر يعتبر ان قواته هي مفتاح
القوه الروسيه في الحرب
ومع تجدد خلافات الجيش المرتبك ومجموعه
صاحبه الانتصارات في اوكرانيا تبقى
المخاوف بشان مدى قدره بوتين على احتواء
وتطويع فيجنر لكن الخبراء ببواطن الامور
في روسيا يرون ان كل ما يحدث ان كان من
الجيش او فاجنر هو مزايدات ومناكفات هدفها
الاخير كسب رضاء ساكن الكرملين
قالت المتحدثات باسم الخارجي الروسيه
ماريا زخرفه في مقابله مع العربيه ان
العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا تهدف لوقف
اراقه الدماء في دومباس الذي استمر
لثمانيه اعوام
والناموسكو ستقضي على الهجوم الاوكرانيه
المضاده واشارت زخرفه الى ان عده الدول
قدمت رؤيتها في مبادرات لحل الازمه
الاوكرانيه وان المبادره الصينيه هي
الاكثر تماشيا مع نهج موسكو كما اضافت
زخرفها ان المبادره الصينيه تحترم سياده
روسيا ولا تؤجز الصراع مشيره في الوقت
ذاته الى مبادره اخرى للحل قدمتها جنوب
افريقيا وعن علاقات موسكو بالدول العربيه
اكدت ان علاقات روسيا مبنيه على الاحترام
المتبادل والمصالح المشتركه
هذا واعلنت الرئاسه الروسيه ان بوتين
سيستقبل وفدا افريقيا في مدينه السبت
المقبل لمناقشه مبادره السلام تلك بشان
اوكرانيا
الى ان روسيا لا يمكنها اظهار حسن
نيه الى ما لا نهايه فيما يتعلق بالوضع
حول صفقه الحبوب لان الغرب لا يفيد
الاتفاقيات
وينضم الينا من ابو ظبي عبر زوم فيتاليين
الدبلوماسي الاوكراني اهلا بك معنا سيد
فيتالي يعني ما هو ردكم على كلام
المتحدثه باسم الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا
بعزم روسيا القضاء على الهجوم الاوكراني
المضاد وما المعلومات المتوفره لديكم حول
التقدم في تلك المنطقه
مساء الخير الكرام اولا اريد ان اعلق على
مقاله زخاره وبالنسبه لاراقه
فاروسيا كالعاده تتلاعب بالحقيقه وتحاول
تضليل العالم
واقول لكم يعني من قام باراكه الدماء
الاوكرانيين هو من مسؤول لهذه الجريمه انه
بسيط يجب علينا ناخذ ارقام وحقائق فقط على
سبيل المثال يعني حسب المعطيات الامم
المتحده نتيجه اعمال الحربيه في دونباس
عام 2020 قتل ثمانيه اشخاص 2021 سبعه
اشخاص
قتل الاوكرانيون بسبب اعمال الحربيه
ولماذا بدات هذه الاعمال بسبب التدخل لو
احتلال جزء من دون باس من قبل روسيا عام
2014 قبل هذا الاحتلال الاجرامي كان
الاوكرانيون باص يعيشون بالسلامه والامان
كامل ولكنه التي تتحدث عن جماعات تصفها
بالنازيه المتطرفه التي كانت تقتل الروس
في مناطق كانت تريد ان تنضم الى روسيا ولا
تريد ان تكون في الجانب الاوكراني
يا استاذ انا من سكان واعرف ما اقولهم ما
كانت اي يعني مجموعات القشيه نزيه انا
يعني سكان في تلك المنطقه وعارف ان نحن
كنا نعيشين بالسلامه والامان كامل روسيا
قالت وحولت حياه الاوكرانيين في الدنباس
الى الجحيم
ولكن اراقه الدماغ الحقيقيه في بدات في 24
فبراير العام الماضي
الحرب العدوانيه الشامله على اوكرانيا
واندمرت بالكامل مدن دنباص العديده
وجود مثل هذه الجامعات انذاك ما كان يقض
مضاجع روسيا وهل اتخذت يكفي من اجراءات
لاعطاء ضمانات للروس من شان امنهم وبشان
امن من يواليهم في الداخل الاوكراني انذاك
قبل بدايه الحرب
يعيشون اوكرانيون يعني انا كمان اوكرانيا
نعم انا يعني احكي اللغه الروسيه ولكن نحن
انا اوكرانيا ما كان عندنا الاوكرانيين
الموالين او يعني لروسيا او موالين يعني
اوكرانيين يعني
هل تنفي وجود جماعات تصفها روسيا بالنازيه
بغض النظر عن وصفك انت لها ولكن تلك التي
تصفها روسيا بالنازيه هل هي موجوده وهل
اتخذت الحكومه الاوكرانيه ما يكفي من
اجراءات لطمانه الجانب الروسي
هذه يعني فكره وجود النزيه في اوكرانيا
اخترعت عروسيا
كحوج كحوش للتدخل الى اوكرانيا وفي محاوله
احتلال اوكرانيا المزيه غير موجوده في
اوكرانيا المزيه اليوم موجوده في روسيا
روسيا
العالم الروسي وهذه الايديا عشيه يعني
يعني في اصله لانها تقول ان الشعب روسيا
الاخرى وفوق الاوكرانيين ولازم ان نقتل
الاوكرانيين ولازم
تدميرك الدوله
سنتحدث معك في الجزء الثاني عن نقطه
المفاوضات حيث شدد نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
القومي الروسي ديمتري مدفادف على ضروره ان
تمتد المنطقه العازله التي تحدث عنها
بوتين لتكون على طول حدود لفيف على الحدود
البولنديه في اشاره لنزع سلاح اوكرانيا
بالكامل ومن جهه اخرى قال مد تواطئ الغرب
الذي وصفه بالمؤكد فاستهداف خطاي نوت
ستريم يرفع جميع القيود حتى الاخلاقيه
لضرب خطوط الاتصالات لاعداء روسيا في
اعماق المحيط
من جديد سيد فيتالي يعني لماذا لا تقربون
المسافه بينكم وبين الروس يعني
ماريا زخرفه تتحدث عن عده مبادرات الاقرب
للروس هي المبادره الصينيه تحدثت ايضا عن
مبادره جنوب افريقيا وايضا جهود عربيه
الى اي الى اي ربما جهه تودون ان تكونوا
اقرب او تتحاوروا هل الى الجهه الخارجيه
الرسميه مثل مريم خروفه التي تتحدث وتعطي
اشارات ايجابيه عن مبادرات ومفاوضات ام
الى الذي يتحدث عن ضروره نزع السلاح في
اوكرانيا يعني يؤخذ عليكم انكم متصلبون في
موقفكم بالنسبه للمفاوضات
نحن لا ناخذ في اعتبار اي مبادرات
واقتراحات تؤدي الى وقت هذا العدوان على
حساب اوكرانيا يعني تجميد الصراع او
التنازل عن الاراضي الاوكرانيه
بنسبه لنا الشرط الوحيد للتحقيق السلام
والعادل والمستدام هو انسحاب او طرد روسيا
من ارضنا المحتله ومعاقبه المجرمين على
هذا العدوان الاستعماري اليوم صيغه
السلامه الاوكرانيه اقترحها الرئيس
اوكرانيا واقردها الجمعيه العامه
بالاغلبيه العظمى هي افضل الصيغه للتواصل
الى السلام في نفس الوقت نحن على استعداد
لمواصله تحرير ارضنا بالقوه
وشركائنا مستعدون لدعمنا يدعها شركائنا
بدعم اوكرانيا مهما استغرق الامر وسيتواصل
دعم براني طالما كان ذلك الضروريا يعني
سنحرر ارضا ذلك لابد لاي حرب ان تنتهي
بتفاوض
هل هناك اي شيء من المبادرات المطروحه
حاليا اي بند او اي مبادره كامله يمكن ان
تكون اقرب الى ما تتصورونه ان كان فيما
يتعلق بالمبادره الصينيه بعيده عنكم
يبدوها المبادره جنوب افريقيا ايضا
ترفضونها تماما هل يمكن ان تعطيه انا
موقفا حول ذلك
طبعا نحن جاهزين لاجراء المفاوضات بعد
انسحاب او طرد القوات الروسيه من ارضنا
يعني بعد انسحاب الروسي نحن جاهزين ونجلس
على طاوله المفاوضات ولكن قبل الانسحاب
غاب يعني مستحيل بالنسبه لنا ونحن مناطق
يعني تقصد يعني حتى من
من دوني من شبه جزيره القرم من كل هذه
المواقع نعم يعني نحن يعني نقول عن الحدود
معترف بها الدوليه ونحن الصندقرر ارضنا في
تلك الحضور عن طريق انسحاب الاحتلال او
دحره بالقوه ولكن هذا الكلام حلما بالنسبه
الى البعض بعدما حققه الروس هناك حتى
بالنسبه الى الدول الغربيه هل تعتقد ان
الصوت العاقل في الغرب يعتقد بان روسيا
يمكن ان تنسحب من شبه جزيره القرم
نحن نقول نحن لا نعيش يعني في الاوهام
يعني او في العالم والافتراضي نحن واثقين
بقوتنا ونحن نقول او انسحبت روسيا او نقوم
بالبحر الاحتلال والطرد هذا الاحتلال من
اراضينا في الحدود معترف بها الدوليه خلال
هذه العمليه او العمليه التاليه اذا طلب
الامر لهذا لان القضيه قضيه مصيريه
بالنسبه لنا نحن لا نتحدث عن الارض نحن
نتحدث عن الشعب الاوكراني يعاني ويقتل في
الاحتلال المستوي على سبيل المثال ابوشه
وبردانكا خير دليل ما تفعله روسيا مع
الاوكرانيين في المناطق المحتله ترتاكم
جريمه لبعض الجمعيه ولا يمكننا ان نسمح
بحدود هذه الجريمه ونحن جالسين في
نكتفي معك بهذا القدر شكرا جزيلا طبعا
موسكوتان في هذه الاتهامات وتتهم اوكرانيا
بضرب العمق الروسي حتى من خلال عمليات هنا
وهناك
واي يعني مسؤول روسي يمكنه الرد عبر منابل
العربيه على هذا الكلام فدياني فيتالي
الدبلوماسيه الاوكرانيه عبر زوم من ابوظبي
شكرا جزيلا لك
وفيما يتعلق بتطورات المعارك على الارض
قال الامين العام للناتو يونس ان القوات
الاوكرانيات تحرر المزيد من الاراضي وان
تقدمها يثبت ان دعم الناتو يحدث فرقه
نلتقي هنا بينما تشن اوكرانيا هجوما مضادا
كبيرا لا يزال في الايام الاولى ولا نعرف
ان كان سيمثل نقطه تحول في الحرب لكننا
نرى ان الاوكرانيين يحرزون تقدما ويحررون
المزيد من الاراضي نعلم ان المزيد من
المكاسب تزيد قوه اوكرانيا على طاوله
المفاوضات وكلما زادت مكاسب اوكرانيا زاد
احتمال ان يدرك الرئيس بوتين انه لا يمكنه
الفوز في ساحه المعركه وعليه التفاوض على
سلام عادل ان التقدم الذي نراه على الارض
يوضح ان الدعم الذي يقدمه حلفاء النيتو
يحدث فرقا حقيقيا في ساحه المعركه
كشف المستشار الالماني استراتيجيه جديده
للامن القومي الالمانيه تركز على امن
الطاقه والصين ووصفات استراتيجيه الامن
القومي الالماني روسيا بانها اكبر تهديد
جدي للنظام الدولي واوروبا كما نصت على ان
روسيا تهدد الديمقراطيه في اوروبا ويجب
التصدي لها كما اشددت الاستراتيجيه
الجديده على ضروره الالتزام بمسار الناتو
وتخصيص اثنين بالمئه من الناتج للانفاق
الدفاعي استراتيجيه الامن القومي
الالمانيه طالبت ايضا بانشاء مركز فيدرالي
لمواجهه الهجمات الخارجيه بينما شددت
وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه على ان الامن في
القرن 21 يعني الا تتجسس الصين على
الهواتف
لقد رسخنا هذا في استراتيجيه الامن القومي
الالماني بما ينعكس بشان الصين انها اللغه
التي تقول بوضوح شديد لا نريد الفصل نريد
عدم المخاطره لان الصين ستستمر في النمو
الاقتصادي كما يجب الا يضعف اندماج الصين
في التجاره العالميه العلاقات الاقتصاديه
العالميه ولكن في نفس الوقت علينا ان
ننتبه للقضايا الامنيه التي نواجهها
[موسيقى]
في العربيه 360 ايضا
اوروبا تتوعد طرفي الصراع في السودان
بالعقوبات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اكدت الخارجيه الامريكيه
ان الوزير انطوني بلينكن سيزور الصين
الاحد المقبل ولمده يومين وذكرت الوزاره
ان بلينكن سيلتقي خلال الزياره نظيره
الصيني لمناقشه اداره مسؤوله للعلاقات
الثنائيه
هذا وافادت وسائل اعلام رسميه بان وزير
الخارجيه الصيني
بانه يتعين على الولايات المتحده التوقف
عن التدخل في شؤون البلاد وان تراعي
الشواغل الاساسيه للصين مثل قد تايوان
ما كادت علاقات الولايات المتحده والصين
تتحسن عقب حادثه من طاب التجسس الصيني حتى
نشبت ازمه جديده عنوانها كوبا الموضوع بدا
باعلان وولد اليوم يوم الخميس بالاحرى عن
ان كوبا تستضيف قاعده تجسس صينيه سريه
تركز على الولايات المتحده وهو ما اكده
البيت الابيض يوم السبت في بيان مقال
لواشنطن بوست طرح تساؤلا ما الدير في تجسس
الصين على الولايات المتحده اذا كانت
الاخيره تقوم بالامر نفسه والوجود الروسي
في كوبا ليس بالحديث وقد كان للاتحاد
السوفيتي اكبر مركز تنصت خارج الاتحاد في
كوبا منذ عقود وانا ذاك كانت واشنطن على
استعداد للمخاطره بحرب لازاله الصواريخ
النوويه السوفياتيه من كوبا لكنها تغاضت
عن مركز التجسس على الاتصالات على الجانب
الاخر اشار المقال الى ان الاستخبارات
الامريكيه لديها اكبر شبكه تنصت تجسس في
العالم وكشف عن جزء منها عبر تسريبات
ادوارد شنودن وتسريبات ملفات البانتاجون
هذه التسريبات بينت ان وكاله الامن
القوميه الامريكي تجمع كميات هائله من
الاتصالات من جميع انحاء العالم وانها
تتجسس على الاصدقاء والاعداء على حد سواء
وفي الوقت الحاضر تتعاون الولايات المتحده
بانتظام في جمع المعلومات الاستخباريه
بشان الصين مع حلفاء لها مثل استراليا
ونيوزيلندا كما انها ترسل طائره استطلاع
خاصه بها قرب المجال الجوي الصيني الصحيفه
اعتبرت ان اي معلومات قد يجمعها الصينيون
في كوبا لن تكون بذات القدر مقارنه بما
تجمعه الولايات المتحده عن الصين وانه لا
يجب ان يكون سببا لنصف الجهود المبذوله
لتحسين العلاقات مع تكين اخيرا وبخصوص
العلاقات مع كوبا قالت واشنطن بوست فان
الولايات المتحده ربما دفعت كوبا لاحضان
الصين بالعقوبات المفروضه منذ اكثر من 60
عاما عليها ومع مواجهه كوبا ازمه اقتصاديه
حاده كانت مليارات بكين امرا لا يمكن
لهافانا ان ترفضه معنا من واشنطن مدير
مركز التحليل السياسي العسكري في معهد
هاتسن ومن موسكو معنا بسام البني الكاتب
والباحث السياسي اهلا بكما ابدا معك استاذ
ريتشاردس هل تعتقد ان الولايات المتحده
اخطات بما فيه الكفايه لكي تدفع بكوبا الى
احضان الصين بسبب العقوبات المفرطه عليها
يمكنك ان تجادل بصحه هذا الامر
فالثوره في كوبا انتجت قياده شيوعيه كانت
مقربه بصوره اساسيه مع موسكو وبكين وفي
جميع الاحوال
ادى هذا
الى ذلك التقارب الذي تم
مشاهدته في الاوقات الاخيره لكن يبدو
بالنسبه لي ان ان حتى لو قامت الولايات
المتحده بازاله هذه العقوبات هل سوف تبقى
مع الصين ام تعود للولايات المتحده قد
يساهم هذا الامر لكنه قد لا يكون هو
العامل اكثر اهميه في هذه الظروف
يعني لماذا برايك تغضب الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه من
مجرد فكره منشاه تجسسيه صينيه في كوبا مع
انه الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لم تترك
حليفا او صديقا او عدوا الا وتجسست عليه
اخر الحلقات كما نتذكر شبكه الدرونز التي
تجمع وتربط بين اليابان وتايوان والولايات
المتحده الامريكيه ما الذي يزعج الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه
خصوصيه ذات طبيعه حساسه بالنسبه للولايات
المتحده
فقد تتحلى الامريكيون عن كوبا بعد
ان
دخلت
بعض القوى الاجنبيه مثل الصين وروسيا
انذاك
والسياسيون الامريكيون يدركون بان بان
هناك بعض الجهه الاخرى التي كانت تدعم
كوبا بطريقه ما هذا الامر قد يكون جزءا من
السياسه الامريكيه وكوبا هي ليست البلد
الوحيد فنحن نرى
الامر يتكرر في الصين وفي بعض دول امريكا
اللاتينيه احيانا لاغراض الفضاء او احيانا
من اجل لاغراض لاغراض شروطيه هذا جزء من
التنامي في جمع المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه بين الصين وبعض الدول في
امريكا اللاتينيه لا لذا بصوره عامه فانه
يثير المخاوف بالنسبه للولايات المتحده
ولا اقول انه يبعث على الغضب الولايات
المتحده تسعى لحد من ذلك استاذ بسام البني
اذا ما ربطنا كل هذا بالعلاقه مع روسيا او
من حيث روسيا هي معنيه بالموضوع ايضا كيف
يمكن ان
نقارب هذا الملف الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
لا تزال قائمه والولايات المتحده تقول
انها تسعى من خلال زياره بلينكن الى اداره
مسؤوله
للعلاقات الثنائيه مع الصين هل تعتقد انه
تركيز امريكا الكامل الان على روسيا
والحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه سيدفعها الى
اتخاذ سياسات اكثر عقلانيه مع الصين تهدئ
العلاقات بين الطرفين او ليس بالضروره
مساء الخير استاذي الكريم مساء الخير على
ضيفك من واشنطن يعني ليس من المعقول ان
نقول ان الصين ممكن ان تقبل بما تقوله
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من اداره من
اداره مسؤوله لاننا نشاهد المسلسل ذاته
الذي حدث مع روسيا قبل حين كنا قد سمعنا
من الولايات المتحده الامريكيه انه يجب
التفاوض مع روسيا وحدثت مفاوضات ومن ثم
جاءت طلبات الامنيه التي تقدمت بها روسيا
في نهايه 2021 هل كانت نتيجه تعجرف الكامل
وكان الرد العمليه العسكريه الخاصه في
اوكرانيا دعني اقول لك ان
حال
البلدين متشابه للغايه وعجرفه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه والبلطجه الامريكيه
السياسيه والاستخباراتيه والمعلوماتيه
والاقتصاديه في العالم هي من دفعت بالصين
وروسيا للتقارب وهي من دفعت بكوبا للتقارب
اكثر مع الصين وروسيا والولايات المتحده
الامري كيه لا تفهم الا اللغه القوه يعني
بالتجسس على دول اوروبيه
وماذا يعني وماذا يعني ذلك يعني هل هل هل
حلال على امريكا حرام على روسيا والصين
يعني الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا تتجسس
فقط بل لديها سفاراتها كلها تابعه ومخصص
متخصصه بالتجسس على الدول التي تقيم بها
هذه نقطه اضيف الى ذلك ان لدى الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه 685
قاعده عسكريه خارج اراضيها في 80 دوله هم
يعني يسيرون هذه الدول كما يشاء بقوه
السلاح الموجود على تلك الاراضي اللهم الا
بعض الدول التي تتمسك بسيادتها وهذا يعني
اننا امام بلطجه امريكيه بحته لا يمكن لها
الا ان تواجه بالقوه وتواجه بنفس الموازين
يعني اذا قامت الصين مثلا بانشاء قاعده
تجسس في كوبا هل هذا حلال حرام عليها يعني
او حلال
لنرى الرد الامري كي او من منظوره هو
تحديدا
يتحدث استاذ بسام البني سيد ريتش عن عما
يسميه عجرفه وبلطجه امريكيه على كافه
الصعود ويسال هل يعني حلال على امريكا
وحرام على روسيا والصين ودول اخرى ان تقوم
بعمليات التجسس هذا هذه ان كانت تخدم
مصالحها
الولايات المتحده
لا تقول هذا الامر
ولا تقولوا بان روسيا والصين تنتهكان بعض
القوانين من خلال التجسس ترغب بالحد من
ذلك
لان هذا لا يعود بمزايا كثيره على
الولايات المتحده الاخيره تسعى لاقناع دول
اخرى من استضافه اي قواعد او مرافق تجسس
صينيه روسيه
وتسعى لمساعده دول اخرى من اجل تعزيز
الدفاعاتها الفضائيه الالكترونيه من اجل
اعمال التجسس الالكتروني
الامر فقط
لانه يصب في مصلحه الولايات المتحده بان
لا يكون هناك بعض الدول المعاديه لامريكا
وقيامها باستضافه تلك لا اقول بان
الولايات المتحده
تحق لها ان ان تقيم قواعد تجسس او دون
سماح لجهات اخرى ان تفعل الشيء ذاته
نعم سيد بسام يعني فعليا لماذا يعني
تطلب الولايات المتحده الامريكيه برايك ان
نتفهم غضبها او العالم يتفهم غضبها من
موضوع التجسس الصيني في كوبا او غيرها من
المناطق ولكنها لا تستوعب الغضب الروسي من
احتماليه انضمام اوكرانيا الى الناتو ونشر
اسلحه على حدودها كيف يمكن تفسير هذه
الازدواجيه الامريكيه
هذا نتيجه للتسعينيات القرن الماضي عندما
كانت روسيا جاسيه على الركب وتفردت
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بالهيمنه على
العالم وكان قرارها ينفذ حتى في روسيا على
مستوى يعني
الاسلحه النوويه كان هناك مراقبون
امريكيون كموظفون رسميون يداومون هنا في
روسيا ويضعون العالم الامريكي على
طاولاتهم ضمن روسيا يعني عندما روسيا
ارادت استعاده سيادتها جنونهم وبداوا
باتهام بوتين بانه ديكتاتور وانه الى اخره
ولكن عندما يلسن الرئيس الروسي قصف البيت
الابيض في عام 1973 كانوا يقولون ان هذا
دفاع عن الديمقراطيه والحريه ولكن عندما
اراد روسيا ان يحافظ على مصالح روسيا
ارادوا ان يسموه ديكتاتورا وقتل قاتلا
وسفاحا والى اخره الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه يا استاذتي الكريمه متعوده على
انها اصبحت الامر الناهي في العالم عندما
تخرج لك لها دول وتقول لها لا هي تشيط هذه
الدول بشكل كامل حتى الابسط الحركات
تشيطنها ولا يمكن لردع الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الا بايجاد صواريخ كازمه
الكاريبي على حدودها في كوبا اوكاراغوا او
دول اخرى او فنزويلا مثلا عندها ستقول لك
نعم انا مهدده تعالوا لنجلس على طاوله
المفاوضات فعندما اكتشف السوفييت وجود
الصواريخ في تركيا في ازمه الكاريبي وضعوا
صواريخ في كوبا وقد ردخ وقتها الرئيس
الامريكي للمفاوضات واغزال تلك الصواريخ
من كلا البلدين اليوم
ايضا جزءا من اي سياسه دوليه يعني لماذا
ايضا نقول بانه حلال على روسيا والصين
وحرام على امريكا فيما يتعلق بعامل القوه
لانه لما تكون القوه مع الصين وروسيا لا
نرى ان الاختلافات فيما هما متهمتان به
ايضا لا نرى اختلافا كبيرا في طبيعه
السياسه المتبعه من قبلهما ثم اليس روسيا
والصين
جزءا من النظام العالمي المهيمن على
العالم كعضوين دائمين في الامم المتحده في
مجلس الامن الم يرسي الم يوافقا على ارساء
هذا النظام العالمي الجديد الذي تقوده
الولايات المتحده
من الذي شطب استاذي الكريم من الذي شطب
النظام العالمي ما الذي شطبه ليس في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه خارج نطاق
الامم المتحده ذهبت وقصفت العراق اليس هي
من ذهبت وقصفت وقسمتها روسيا والصين من
حقهما الدفاع عن نفسهما لانهما ليست دوله
معتدليتان هما لا يريدان مخالفه القانون
الدولي لماذا هناك يمكن مثلا في كوسوفي حق
تقرير المصير يدعموه ويدعمه انفصال كوسوفو
وعن صربيا
على سبيل المثال لا يقولون لك ليس هناك حق
تقرير ماذا يعترفون بمبدا الصين الواحده
ويتحرشون بالصين عن طريق ارسال السفن
الحربيه الى مضيق تايوان لماذا كل هذا
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه يا اخي لا
تفهم الا كل الا لغه قوه هي دوله كابوي هو
ثقافتهم ثقافه الكابوي عندما تكون الرعب
متوازي عندها لا يكون هناك عندما يكون
على الاخر بانه الولايات المتحده الحديث
عن الحكومه عن سياسه الحكومه الامريكيه او
الحكومات المتعاقبه والحديث ليس عن الشعوب
نتحدث عن السياسه الرسميه للحكومات
الامريكيه المتعاقبه رايك سيد ريتشارد بان
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه لا تفهم الا
بمنطق القوه
اذا ما تحدثتم عن القوه الناعمه والقوه
الاقتصاديه
فان الولايات المتحده تتفهم ذلك لكن ما
نراه في حاله روسيا والصين
بالمقابل مع الولايات المتحده
هو اختلافات طبيعيه من وجهات النظر
فالولايات المتحده كانت تنظر الى العالم
في تسعينيات القرن الماضي بطريقه مختلفه
عما كانت تراه الصين وروسيا وتسعيان
لتحسين اوضاعهم في حين ان الامر لم يرق لي
الولايات المتحده لهاتين البلدين لتحرير
انفسهما من النظام القائم انذاك في حين ان
الامر
لم يكن مناسبا مناسبا لروسيا وتركيا
واعتقدتها انهما بمقدورهن ان يصبح افضل
لذا كانت هناك قيود من الولايات المتحده
لوضع حد ذلك مما ادى الى حاله من الصدام
لتغيير الاوضاع وتجلى هذا الصدام في
اوكرانيا وتايوان والولايات المتحده
وحلفائها ايضا سوف يفعلون نفس الشيء شكرا
نكتفي بهذا القدر شكرا جزيلا مركز تح
[موسيقى]
قال مدير الاعلام في حكومه اقليم دارفور
موسى داوود ان عدد القتلى في مدينه
الجنينه بولايه غرب دارفور بلغ اكثر من
الف شخص ومشيرا الى ان القتلى ينتمون الى
الطرفين المتحاربين في المدينه وهما قبيله
المساليد المدعومه من قوات الدعم السريع
وجماعات من قبائل عربيه بالمنطقه واضاف
داوود كل المؤسسات الصحيه الان في المدينه
خرجت من الخدمه تماما
[موسيقى]
اتهمت قوه الدعم السريع في السودان الجيش
بالسعي لاشعال حرب قبليه في اقليم دارفور
وبزج مكونات من الاقليم في مواجهات ذات
طابع قبليه فقال الدعم السريع في بيان ان
الجيش السوداني حول الحرب من سياسيه الى
قباليه بين مكونات الاقليم داعيا مواطني
اقليم
الاستجابه لمخططات الجيش السوداني بحسب ما
جاء في البيان
كان الاتحاد الاوروبي هدد بمحاسبه طرفي
النزاع في السودان بسبب استمرار المعارك
وخرق هدن وقف اطلاق النار واضافها الاتحاد
الاوروبي ان العقوبات ستفرض على طرفي
النزاع في السودان بشان انتهاك القانون
الانساني الدولي وعرقلت عمل الفرق الامميه
في ايصال المساعدات الانسانيه الى المناطق
المتضرره بسبب المعارك واجبار اكثر من
مليون شخص على النزوح وفق تقارير امميه
[موسيقى]
في العربيه 360 ايضا المجرم الذي لم نعرف
بعد من اين اتانا ارتكب جريمته وهرب
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد دفع الرئيس الامريكي
السابق دونالد ترامب ببراءته في قضيه
الوثائق السريه وخرج بعدها ليوكيل
الاتهامات للديمقراطيين وعلى راسهم بايدن
ويبرئ ساحهته لكن نيويورك تايمز خطابه
وكشفت عن مدى تناقده مع الدستور الامريكي
نتابع
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هذا سياسي مثل ما يحدث بشكل صريح من امه
فاشيه او شيوعيه وسوف يسجل هذا اليوم
باعتباره عارا وسيظل جو بايدن في الذاكره
الى الابد باعتباره الرئيس الاكثر فسادا
في تاريخ بلدنا والاهم من ذلك الرئيس الذي
حاول مع عصابه البلطجيه المقربه وغير
الاسوياء والماركسيين تدمير الديمقراطيه
الامريكيه
التهديد بسجن لمده 400 عام لحيازه اوراق
الرئاسيه من اكثر النظريات القانونيه
بشاعه على الاطلاق لاي محكمه امريكيه
قانون الوثائق الرئاسيه يقضي بحفظ السجلات
الرسميه للرؤساء السابقين في الارشيف
الوطني ويميز القانون بين السجلات الرسميه
والوثائق الشخصيه
يتخذ الرئيس قرار الاحتفاظ بالمواد
الشخصيه خلال فتره ولايته وفقا لتقدير فقط
القانون لا يمنح الرئيس حريه التصرف
المطلق ويتعين على الرئيس المغادر فصل
الوثائق الشخصيه عن السجلات الرسميه قبل
ترك منصبه
كنت اتفاوض مع الارشيف الوطني حتى تمت
مداهمه منزلي في فلوريدا
لا يؤسس قانون السجلات الرئاسيه عمليه
تفاوض بين الرئيس والارشيب والمداهمه جرت
بعد عده طلبات حكوميه لاستعاده الوثائق
خلافا لك رئيس لم يكن لبايدن بصفته نائبا
للرئيس اي سلطه لرفع السريه عن الوثائق
يتمتع نواب الرئيس بصلاحيه رفع السريه عن
بعض المواد
ارسل بايدن 1850 صندوقا الى جامعه ديلور
وهو يرفض التخلي عنها
تبرع بايدن بالوثائق عام 2012 عن فتره
عمله كعضو في مجلس الشيوخ ممثلا للولايه
ولا يشمله قانون السجلات الرئاسيه
[موسيقى]
حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من واشنطن
الكاتب الصحفي بيت الروف اهلا بك معنا سيد
بيتر يعني
مغالطات قانونيه حول تصريح اخر تصريح
لدونالد ترامب بعد محاكمته امس هل لمصلحه
ترامب القانونيه ان يورد او يصر على هذه
المغالطات والاهانات لان كان او غيره يعني
كيف يمكن تفسيرها الا ترتقي وتضره ترتقي
الى تهمه اخرى ربما تضره في المستقبل
شكرا جزيلا على استضافه ولابد لي ان اقول
بصفه
صحفيا متحفظا فلا اعتقد ان نيويورك تايم
قد تكون محقه في كل ما
ذهبت اليه
في اجابت في الدستور السيد بيتر اجابت
بالدستور
كل نقطه قالها ترامب بالدستور يعني مثلا
هو يتحدث ترامب يقول انه يتخذ الرئيس قرار
الاحتفاظ بالمواد الشخصيه خلال فتره
ولاياته وفقا لما قالوا نيويورك تايمز
تقول القانون لا يمنح الرئيس حريه التصرف
المطلق ويتعين على الرئيس المغادر فصل
الوثائق الشخصيه عن الوثائق الرسميه يعني
هذا بده سطور
ليس تحليل
مجرد صحيفه وليست محكمه قانونيه وليست
بقاظم وهي تفسر ما تفهم من القانون الرئيس
ترامب يفسر القانون كما يتفهمه وكما يفترض
انه قد علم بذلك من مستشاريه القانونيين
الفرق بين
السجلات الرئاسيه والسجلات الخاصه
تكون مساله تابعه للرئيس وليس للكونغرس
وليس للملفات الارشيفات الوطنيه يبدو
بالنسبه لي وبصوره متزايده ان مزاعم
الرئيس ترامب بانه له الحق بان يحتفظ ببعض
المسجلات غير السريه ويسرح عنها بانها
خاصه وانه قد سمح له بالحفاظ بالاحتفاظ
بها قد يكون له ارضيه مقنعه اكثر مما كان
يعتقد ولا بد لي ان اقر بانني لست محامي
هنا وانا لست خبيرا في
في هذه الزوايا الضيقه من القانون لكن
بناء على ما قراته وبناء على ما قاله
للبعض عندما تحدثت اليهم بشان هذه المساله
اناس مطلعين ترامب لديه قضيه اكثر مما
يسعى البعض للنظر اليها بطريقه مختلفه
ولكن فيما يتعلق
يعني انت من حيث كاتب صحفي وليس كقانون او
محامي كما تحدثت الى ما تعزوا هذا الاصرار
على متابعه هذا الموضوع قضائيا في واشنطن
او في الولايات المتحده ضد ترامب تحديدا
اذا كانت ترامب يقول انه الطرف الاخر يريد
حصره في الزاويه ويريد منعه من الترشح
للانتخابات فهو في استطلاعات الراي كنتيجه
يعرف جيدا انه يرفع من اسهمه وهذا واضح
كيف تفسر ذلك اذا هل يحاول هل يلعب الطرف
الاخر ضد مصالحه الشخصيه
اعتقد ان بعض الديمقراطيين في انحاء
البلاد وحتى بعض الديمقراطيين في هذه
العمليه التي نشدها يسعون
للتاثير على فرص ترامب للفوز بالبيت
الابيض هذا امر واضح كما ان هناك بعض
الديمقراطيين الذين كرسوا انفسهم من اجل
نشر هذه
الادعاءات الكاذبه وبعض الملفات التي ادى
الى تحقيق مولر بالاضافه الى اشياء اخرى
والتي افضت الى اتهام
ترامب مع روسيا وهناك بعض
الاطراف من الحزبين الذين دفعوا بهذه
القصه لاسباب سياسيه وهناك ايضا اطراف من
الحزبين الذين دفعوا بجوانب من هذه القصه
لاسباب سياسيه اعتقد انه من باب الانصاف
ان نقول ان السيد ترامس لم يمنح نفس الحيز
الذي حصل عليه بعض السياسيين الاخرون في
اليسار واليمين في الولايات المتحده لانه
شخص معروف
[موسيقى]
يشعر بما يقوم به اعدائه السياسي انه ليس
جورج w انه ليس برونالد ريجن ولا يتصرف
كما يفعل
خصومه السياسيون على اساس انهم قد يمكن ان
يصبحوا اصدقائه في فتره المساء ترامب على
مدارس الساعه دائما يقوم
بالدفاع عن اجل عن اجندته حاله حاله
الديمقراطيين في النظام السياسي الامريكي
فانا لا اعتقد ان السيد اوباما
كان
بنفس الشده التي نشهدها الان في شخصيه سيد
ترامب لكن اوباما لم يكن يحاول الفوز على
الجمهورين كان لديه مكاسبه الخاصه بل عمه
رم فهو شخصيه ذات خصال مختلفه وان بعض
هذه الخصائص
وبعض هذه الخصال يجب ان تقيده الى حد
ولنعلم بان الدعم الذي يحظى به الان لكسب
الترشح قد لا يكون كافيا لكسب
الرئاسه وهذا قد لا يساعده على المدى
الطويل
كاتب صحفي من واشنطن شكرا جزيلا لك
[تصفيق]
سنتحدث الان طاهر عن تزايد الطلب على
السيارات الكهربائيه الذي ربما يقود
العالم نحو تقنيات خطيره تشكل تحديات
بيئيه وصحيه نتحدث عن معدن النيكل المكون
المهم في صناعه بطاريات السيارات
الكهربائيه اندونيسيا هي اكبر منتج له
عالميا وتحضر تصديره بشكله الخام للمعالجه
في الخارج بدا قبل اعوام في اندونيسيا
استخدام تقنيه تكرير خام النيكل عبر دمجه
مع حمض الكبريت تحت ضغط وحراره مرتفعين
لانتاج نيكل العالي الجوده عمليه الترشيح
او التكرير هذه تنتج حوالي 20 طنا من ثاني
اكسيد الكربون لكل طن من النيكل وهو الضعف
الكميه المنبعثه بطرق المعالجه التقليديه
لوكاله الطاقه الجويه ولكن على الرغم من
التعهدات الرسميه بالحد من انبعاثات
الكربون وافقت الحكومه الاندونيسيه على
بناء طاقه تعمل بالفحم لدعم معالجه النيكل
لصناعه السيارات الكهربائيه طبعا انتاج
النيكل في اندونيسيا سجل رقما قياسيا بلغ
مليون طن متري قبل عامين وتشير التوقعات
الى ارتفاع الانتاج بحلول عام
2028 الى مليونين و500 الف طن متري سنويا
في الجانب الاقتصادي ايضا اندونيسيا هي
مصدر رئيسي لنسبه كبيره من النيكل
المستخدم في بطاريات سيارات شركات مثل
تسلا وهيونداي وفورد وتشير التوقعات الى
ارتفاع الطلب بحلول عام 2030 بنسبه اثنين
وخمسين في المئه ايضا بدات عده شركات
تستثمر في المصانع الاندونيسيه بعدما
اعلنت شركه كاتل الصينيه وشركه ال جي
الكوريه الجنوبيه وهما من اكبر مصنعي
بطاريات السيارات الكهربائيه في العالم
افتتاح مصانع في اندونيسيا قريبا بقيت
معلومه مهمه هي حجم ما يخلفه مصنع
اندونيسيا من مواد سامه يبلغ 4 ملايين طن
متري سنويا ما يكفي لملء
1667 حوض سباحه اولمبي
الى تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 روسيا
ومصر تعملان على زياده عدد الرحلات الجويه
بين البلدين التصريح والسفير الروسي لدى
القاهره جورجي بوريسينغو
الذي التي هوت بعد
د 6000 يوميا الى اربعه الاف الفائده اذا
هي مشتركه بين الروس الذين تقلصت امامهم
فرص السياحه وبين مصر التي يعاني اقتصادها
وتبحث عن العمله الصعبه
وفي فيديو اليوم انتشر خفر السواحل
الاسبانيه
123 مهاجرا اغلبهم افارقه من قاربين
خشبيين كاناها ايمين في مياه الاطلسيه
تحت جنح الظلام ابحر وتحت جنح الظلام
انقذوا لكن يبقى الظلام الحقيقي هو الذي
وضعهم في هذا الموقف ظلام المستقبل في
اوطانهم
سوره اليوم من كوفنتوس البريطانيه لكنها
التقطت قبل شهور مضت عمل فني اقيم في
المدينه لتخليد ذكرى ضحايا الجائحه وعجوز
بريطانيه تدون اسماء من فقدتهم تبدو
وكانها تكتب في ذكرى الاحباء الذين قتلهم
الوباء الذي لا نعرف حتى الان من اين اتى
ولا كيف اختار ضحاياه ولا ان كان سياتينا
مره اخرى لكننا نعرف انه افلت بجريمته
اقله حتى
الان
هكذا نصل الى ختام العربيه 360 ولكن اخبار
الساعه لا تنقطع فتستمر مع الزميله ميسون
ويهد مساء الخير ميسون
مساء الخير طاهر سنبدا طبعا بتصريحات
الخارجيه الروسيه بانها تتعهد بافشال
الهجوم المضاد لاوكرانيا ايضا سنتحدث
العربيه صحيح سنتحدث ايضا عن الاوضاع
الماساويه للسودانيين وخاصه للفارين من
دارفور ايضا لدينا الصراع الامريكي الصيني
ينتقل الى اعماق البحار عبر كابلات
الانترنت بالاضافه طبعا الى قضيه الموسم
قضيه الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات